two major players were not part of the
talks between the United States and
North Korea today China will want to say
in any new deal because of course North
Korea has been dependent on Beijing for
food energy and trade and Russia fears
the summit could impact its reputation
as a major deal maker in East Asia
according to an online piece by former
Russian diplomat Vladimir Olaf
let's ask experts how China and Russia
may react to any deal and its impact
we welcome historian Victor Davis Hanson
of Stanford's Hoover Institution
Michael malleus biographer and author of
the book dear reader the unauthorized
biography of Kim jong-il and rejoining
us Gordon Chang gentlemen this is just
there's so much I want to unpack with
you Michael I want to start with you
because much has been made of Kim
jong-un's
affection historical affection for his
grandfather and where his grandfather
was in conversations with I think it was
Jimmy Carter right back in this was a 93
and of 93 and he died three weeks later
it even looks kind of heavy
look sky looks a lot like his
grandfather in many ways how does that
might play it might play into this and
then your reaction on the Russia China
issue well a lot of people make fun of
kim jongmin for his haircut and that's
actually very intentional he's doing a
throwback to his grandfather the great
leader Kim il-sung who was the founder
of North Korea who is very much revered
to this day even by refugees as one of
the greatest people who's ever lived
when Kim jong-il took over in 94 that's
when the famine started getting worse he
even launched a campaign called let's
eat two meals a day instead of three to
say that having less food is a good
thing so even his clothing is a
throwback I have the same exact suit Kim
Jong Un's wearing I got in North Korea I
think it looks better on me but the
point is very much optics are a function
there of the regime and anything that he
can do to channel his grandfather's
energy and in fact by law only a
descendant of the great leader Kim
il-sung can be the North Korean leader
which is one of the reasons why he had
his elder brother assassinated because
if there is no Kim jong-nam to take over
it's not like there's a Mike Pence you
have to stick with what you have and
Victor Davis Hanson when Madeline
Albright was there in 2000 she made a
you know a quick pilgrimage to the
memorial for
Kim Jong Un's grandfather Kim il-sung
and that's the great leader that is how
they refer to him there but if you mind
commenting on the China Russia a concern
in this deal any deal that might come
out of this Russia hasn't had any
international clout since it squirmed
into Syria when it was invited in by the
Obama administration otherwise it had
been out of the Middle East for almost
40 years so it's going to try to repeat
that punch above its weight and wiggle
in it has a border with North Korea and
offer us some type of triangulation
maybe help with Iran or something China
North Korea wouldn't be nuclear if it
wasn't for China once a nuclear North
Korea but it doesn't want a nuclear war
it wants the sort of a pitbull on a
Chinese leash that occasionally lets go
and consumes American attention and
resources and it feigns ignorance of
what's happened so it's perplex right
now it's even scared maybe it seems
impossible to imagine that maybe North
Korea might gravitate away toward China
and that's something as far as the
Iranians that's really interesting
because this is their pipeline for
nuclear technology North Korea and China
and all the conventional wisdom said if
you walk away from the Iran deal you
can't cut a deal with North Korea in
fact the opposite is true
waitwait victory where are you you say
we're wrong again I mean Trump was gonna
blow up the world six months ago the
economy was gonna tank we're gonna go
into global depression and in the Iran
deal was gonna screw up anything we
tried to do in North Korea all of that
just so everyone watching knows the
experts in this region for the most part
that the ones are on all the other
cables all night long
have been wrong about Asia for decades
much to the detriment of the United
States of America I think it's I think
Trump was sort of like that you know the
Apple commercial where they won't the
athlete ran in through the hammer into
the screen and it just shattered
everything because he wasn't beholden to
these Pyatt ease and conventional false
wisdoms and one thing we have to do
though or we can't go back to the status
quo so the status quo was it and Trump
inherited a terrible condition of
missiles pointed at us that might have
been nuclear tip once they made that
decision to point a missile at Portland
Trump is basically saying you not only
lost the missiles you lost your entire
nuclear program and that's where we want
to be and I think he can do it and the
other thing is we've really got it this
is we're gonna get medieval pretty soon
because these sanctions are really
biting in the past under the agreed
framework and the six-party talks
strategic patience we always let up I
don't think Trump will on this it's not
going to it's gonna be no sir yeah I
completely agree Gordon I want to play
something for you Jeremy bash former
chief of staff CIA and DOD under Obama
all this is unfolding tonight history in
the making again we'll see what happens
but it's still historic and this is his
take away let's watch the spectacle of
seeing the American flags along with the
dprk flags as the backdrop for that
handshake is really jarring actually to
to see to witness in fact I would say
it's somewhat disgusting it is actually
a debasement of of the American flag the
debasement of the American flag because
we've never had conversations diplomatic
or otherwise Gordon with regimes or
countries who have had human rights
violations and even threatened us never
happened before I cannot believe this
man was a chief of staff for a major
u.s. federal department stunning your
reaction yeah not only have we had
conversations with countries like these
we've given state visits to their
leaders we've had Chinese state assets
you know and so you know clearly we've
got to talk to North Korea it's much
better than the alternative you know
president Trump's maximum pressure
campaign is largely responsible for
getting the North Koreans here if we
have to have our flag next to theirs as
we talk to them so be it the important
point here right now is that president
Trump's talking about a relationship
with the North Koreans that is going to
scare the Chinese and the Russians as
well because it means that we can then
have one more friend in Asia and China
will have one less friend and by the way
Laura that one less friend North Korea
is China's only formal Ally
and so this undercuts this narrative of
China being the global hegemon the US
and terminal decline that the Chinese
will
Eastasia all of that goes out the window
in one summit and you know as I
mentioned if you have to have the
American flag next to the North Korean
one that's a very small price to pay for
a political advantage that's just a
boneheaded comment I'm sorry we had to
play that for you guys Michael when you
go back and I we're talking about a lot
of different aspects of this whole
regime relationship part of the world is
very complicated but when Mao Zedong was
was looking at how North Korea the North
Koreans were were developing and Kim
Mills son and they were going to the old
Stalinist ways they were abandoning
Marxism Leninism but it was very much
the cult of personality
I know Victor's written about this
extensively as has Gordon as as you the
cult of personality in Mount with Mao in
China the Great Leap Forward and also
with Kim Mills son and to some extent
with this young man who's this grandson
we can't we can't look away from that
dynamic either and it's really funny
there's a gigantic statue in North Korea
of Kim il-sung and everyone who visits
has to bow down and put flowers before
it and when they put up originally was
plated in gold and the Chinese
government this was in the 70s said you
know we're communist regimes we
shouldn't be plating giant idols of our
leaders in gold so they changed it to
bronze so but very much North Korea is a
function of this personality cult in
their literature they attack the idea
that a personality cults a bad idea
because from their perspective it is
only the leader who bestows political
life on to the population so you can't
really separate the two however that
does give Kim jong-un some leeway in the
fact that since the leaders will and
ideas are law he's free to do whatever
he wants including contradict himself
and everyone stand and applaud him and
Ellora I'm gonna make one more point
when you play that clip earlier of Ben
Rhodes if you can't pronounce kim jong
un's name correctly maybe you shouldn't
be flapping your gums in this issue and
be Penn State their lane you know okay
Victor Davis Hanson I got 15 seconds
song it up for us well Trump is playing
the good cop now because he's got
realists like Pompeo and Bolton so he
doesn't have to play the bad cop and
he's much better at that role that's new
and then finally as far as the roads in
the final administer
nobody in the Trump administration is
doing what Obama did and trying to
coerce US banks to violate US law to
facilitate liquidity for the Iranians
this is half transparent God good cop
good cop bad cop